i'm completely convinced that the future
of fundraising is going to come in nft
forum not in indiegogo and gofundme
because people have a double asset play
there
i actually think it's how every artist
is going to do album releases in the
future instead of going to a record
label they're going gonna have the fans
be a part of it
so something to put on your radar this
portion is like with me so i think this
is when you need to get selfish like you
need to ask your question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this is the television
and the television is the radio
the 40s [ __ ]
up and who all of you are starting this
way sure uh keep it real short yeah keep
it quick and we're gonna go back around
yeah my name is ivan i am a dentist uh
by training i do ed tech for dentists
and we're actually moving to our medical
to provide a medical device for them as
well that's awesome central valley
central valley very nice
my name is david mohler i'm a serial
entrepreneur
current startup is uh device uh smart
device company smart device company how
long you've been doing it
for three years nice and where are you
based in atlanta georgia very nice
how's it going good to see you donald
wymack capital
um
mortgage broker with the b2b model in
the bay area you met russell a few
months back yes i remember virtually i
remember good to see you again
billy richardson um i'm in the
restaurant business in las vegas very
nice four little restaurants and
throwing my brands up how long you been
doing it uh uh uh 12 years good for you
all in vegas the whole time vegas
yeah of course tough yep
pleasure thank you
ian matthews uh from washington d.c
and uh
i'm here with david same company right
now uh building on what he said uh smart
devices were in the car security
business so it's uh nice and connected
understood
real pleasure
okay
long time yes long time brother yeah so
two in 2009 yeah really really good to
see you yeah
so three-time founder all the investment
space and uh i'm gonna build something
else there
and then i have a bunch of urls that
i've been acquiring that i want to talk
to i love
i love it
monique brown i run an organization that
teaches life skills i also work in film
and television production a little real
estate investment and brand development
for my husband's uh legendary
career and uh
and uh and and film
entertainment life it's awesome it's
great to see you again great thank you
great anybody else joe nope that's it
good we got a nice small group and we
can get we can go very deep today so
let's take advantage of that so let's go
back around and
this is the time to get very selfish and
be very direct with your question i'm
sure some people pick up nuances on it
okay you want to go first all right um
i'll try to keep it try to keep it
concise we'll have some time we've got
three questions for you um
just a little bit of backstory on myself
i was very much like like you as a kid
you know hustler immigrant parents kind
of a hard uh struggle there i ended up
going to dental school i got some really
niche training in my field
which was great but i graduated about
800 grand in student debt which is crazy
but it's it's normal in that i know it
is
i was you know getting ready to come out
and pay that debt and crush it my
daughter was born with a
life-threatening condition and so i
couldn't really do that as a dentist so
i found another way
published a book
sold thousands of copies and that turned
into an online brand which is now like
my edtech business
which does better than i would have done
if i would have done just regular
clinical dentistry good for you so
i built a team around it and now we're
expanding to a private label medical
device as well so i've got a little nice
little business model um
taking some big big steps in that so
my first question is
i'm basically the bottleneck in my
content creation
to create like the pillar hero content i
got to be in there doing surgery or
something and
and teaching
something around that content it's hard
for me to constantly create that content
as the business owner
i'm trying to outsource that to to other
collaborators but kind of having a hard
time getting them to feed that funnel
other collaborators as in other people
executing the actual surgery yes getting
other influencers or people doing
surgery feeding me that content so we
can just repurpose it as a team and turn
that into 20 pieces of content having a
hard time feeding that funnel why
because these guys already make 500 000
a year they don't really need me paying
them a thousand bucks for their content
you know as charity basically so i want
how do i get them to buy into that or
how do i feed the content funnel
um
there's a lot of things there so
the let's talk about the pillar content
and the funnel
is the model that you know obviously i'm
very proud of really working for you
like
macro hero chop it down make it make
that into content that's performing
against the business kpi is that working
it does well when i can feed it i can
feed it myself how how many times are
you refurbishing it
adding new content
no refurbishing the original content so
yeah so the repurposing thing is a very
important combo because
as
most of you probably know so much of my
world from a brand building standpoint
is predicated on that and so much of
that
is predicated on me being filmed doing
stuff and that completely got eliminated
18 months ago i wasn't flying i wasn't
doing this in person
so what ended up happening is at first
we did a lot of stuff through zoom and
things of that nature but that obviously
is a very one-dimensional visual
creative there's only so many times you
can see me with in a t-shirt that you
know and the context matters in feed it
matters
so what ended up happening
when i analyzed the last 18 months i was
thinking about on the flight out here
ironically because i saw a piece of
content do extremely well from three
years ago in the last 24 hours is
wow if drock and i never film another
thing i've put enough film on paper
on wax on youtube that if i remix it
uh in perpetuity i should be able to be
effective with the evergreen content
one of the things most content creators
don't take advantage of enough of is the
repurposing truly understanding what
that means i'll give you an example
i if you've got i assume i'm making some
assumptions so keep me in line here if
your content is you performing
or when you're doing that are you also
looking to camera and do and teaching
and like going through it sometimes yes
so i'm sure you probably have seen this
the co one of things you can do
immediately is how many of the how many
would you say pillar pieces of content
have you created a lot 200 great so
right off the top
there's probably an ungodly amount of
content to be made where you're split
screening like i do
the original piece of content and now
you're just social commentating
contextually on top of it with other
variables
right so
to me
what what's really interesting about the
way i think about content which i do
think for every business here from
vegas restaurants to yours to medical
devices
you know
the whole world is predicated on in on
communication and and does that create
consideration to buy something
what is interesting about how i look at
what i do and what i see working is
my content is pretty evergreen literally
in my hotel before i came here right now
i just produced a split screen
from dailyvee episode 22 from march 16
2016 where the person's question was
some
how do you do what you do and the two
answers were empathy and gratitude and
here we are five years later and it's
like everything that i continue to say
and so i added a piece of content to it
right now and i'm pretty damn sure
that oh i'm sorry so here's this q a
from dailyvee 2022 my split screen my
additional context
went a little bit into gratitude and
this is all improv in my hotel room i
took the cup of coffee got a little
coffee left i'm like this is full
i'm grateful for this what's in here
because i have more than most and then
when i sent it to the team actually
this is why not to show you
um
so in the whatsapp thread where my team
lives
where
this was the original piece of content
they sent me because we're we're doing
this we have the same problem you do
right um
okay so here's the question
this will now be a visual split screen
consumer i'm going you've
march 16 2026 shit's consistent out here
my friends if you deploy these mental
mindsets and at the end of this
and then and then what i sent to the
team was i want the title to say you
have more than most
what's interesting about that what's
interesting for everybody said so this
would be titled you have more than most
i just split screened a piece five years
later i just realized i said 2026 so
i'll have to make a joke of that in a
post edit um
this is a pretty substantially different
piece of content that i'm gonna write
copy to that's gonna really focus on the
gratitude part of the
split screen
but it's i have to do this because i'm
at the mercy of the pillar content
production not being where it's at
because we haven't started moving
if you've done 200
pieces of original pillar content
you probably have
4 000 pieces of micro content that can
be brand or performance based as a
funnel acquisition so i think that's
what you have to think about i think the
concept of
of
the other thing to think through is in a
world of 500k
100 a thousand dollar framework that you
created they make 500k a year they're
doing this basically for charity
if you look at
james
is pillar content as something that
extracts 57 pieces have created for you
because you create post-production from
it
it might put you in a position where
you're willing to pay them 5 000 instead
of 1 000. so i think i think
the answer to the question is
a much deeper thought of post-production
which you don't even have to be the
pillar the bottlenecked of i'm doing the
split screens you probably should as
well because it's it's much more
impactful but don't underestimate hiring
an animator or other people where the
split screen or the post creative
content could be post-produced in
animation or post-producing
video or or overlay wording so it's
post-production so i realize i'm leaving
a lot on the table by not repurposing
that enough
okay and what's fun is whatever i was
going earlier i didn't finish the
thought i'm glad i remembered is what
i'm saying is evergreen that's how i got
to that 2016 thing what i'm saying i'll
never change to the day i die
the slang term
the nuance to something that just
happened so i'm in the evergreen
business and then daily you're using the
context of your industry of the moment i
mean
tomorrow in you know in a week in the
world series a player may take a ball to
the mouth and lose all his teeth and
that's a pop culture moment that might
have you being able to over which will
lead to so much more
relevance
right
he may make a video of a dish in his
of his one of his restaurants four years
ago but something might happen in vegas
tomorrow
that if you post produce on top of it
the way i'm talking about so it's really
the remix it's the djing of the assets
in perpetuity at scale
contextual to the distribution so for
example
to continue to layer on this for
everybody and i'm going deep on this
because this is an answer for all of you
um
it's not only
pop culture relevance like
cody bellinger losing four teeth and
maybe you can figure out what to do with
that it's also distribution
the way you would the way i would talk
if i knew that i'm posting this on
linkedin to get clients is gonna be
different than the way i would talk if
i'm gonna put on tick tock
two platforms that even four years ago
weren't even in play we first met it was
just twitter and facebook that's it and
so it's post-production not only for
what's happening culturally or topical
it's post-production for the
distribution too
those 200 pieces of content if they've
mainly been posted inside of facebook
and instagram have they been done for
pre-roll youtube have we made them for
tick-tock you may never need to do
anything again you have enough work for
the next five years in what we just
talked about the last ten minutes right
okay is it okay i have two more
questions all right
so this one's going a little it's a
little different so
the
medical device space uh and dental
implants they're all huge companies
they're all really really big dogs we're
the underdog uh i've had even ceo of one
of one of them is tell me you know you
better not enter the space you're just
going to wipe the floor with you
basically yeah that's usually the
biggest reason i would enter a space
so we're based we're entering in
for christmas yes that's when we launch
um and kind of do this david and goliath
type of story okay right i don't know
how much to sass the big dogs because
really i don't want you know i don't
have as much funding as they do how
would you play that by fasting them as
much as possible yeah because i'll tell
you why i've always uh you know i've
struggled with this because we have
major clients at vayner who are the
number two in categories and they're
petrified and i'm like you don't
understand
you haven't sassed them or razzed them
or poked them in three decades that's
why you continue to be number
the only way
you know david beats goliath is by going
at it
what are they going to do
like ultimately what's actually going to
happen is you're not important enough
for them to actually spend the money and
reap and resources on it but you poking
them will give you micro market share
growth
so just go go hard on it what are they
going to do
talk it through what are they going to
do out market you the job are you anyway
so the the person in particular who said
he's going to crush us basically he's
already started two implant companies
sold the first 100 million until the
second one 300 million said you know the
next one we're going to price lower than
you
and i have the credibility you don't so
you're basically the fact that he's even
talking to you is already the most
interesting thing to me like the fact
that he even acknowledges you i don't
even ign i would never spend a second on
a company smaller than mine
that that's the most interesting part of
it all
it speaks to in my opinion irrational
competitiveness
or slash emotion
which could end up being the best thing
for you
if you're a thorn in that person's side
he may end up referencing you more which
is going to only help you
i'm fascinated by that if somebody who's
you haven't entered in at all yet and
they've already had two exits of those
sides and this is the third one
price is only just one variable for
example this is where
this is where tick-tock really matters
price is one thing relevance always
beats price people pay more for things
all the time if they think it's better
or cooler or represents them more
price doesn't scare me um what scares me
is if david doesn't understand where the
arbitrage is
how much is the implant
uh so they're going to price out 100
we're going to price we're thinking at
130. yeah i mean i would
i would be
very aggressive on tick-tock very okay
yeah my last question for you gary uh
just as a ceo um
you gotta keep you know you gotta keep
your uh pulse on a lot of [ __ ] yep if
you have family personal family crisis
is going on such as my my daughter's
medical condition it's when the when the
[ __ ] hits the fan basically you still
got a business to run and bills to pay
how do you think straight when
you can't you don't
you don't and i think the biggest thing
i can tell you my friend is
you know as somebody who has not had to
live through
a level of challenge of that level
i feel incredibly inappropriate to speak
to it first second of all what i've
observed from others
the only thing i could tell you that
feels incredibly natural to me is
my number one goal in life is not to
live with regret
i don't think there's a single person on
earth
who
chose their business over their family
that feels great about it when they get
older i think every moment
you spend on your family situation at
the expense of your business is a good
moment to be spent
thank you you got it
david
yeah i'm gonna grab
a prop please
accelerate i like a good problem
please it's a prototype so everyone be
gentle yes
um so my background i studied mechanical
engineering at georgia tech and then
started on the corporate path and
quickly realized that wasn't the best
fit ian was my manager 20 years ago ge i
didn't fire him if that's with you
he didn't probably should have um
i
uh yeah
um
well i interviewed with them they were
one of my investment banking interviews
uh a friend and i tried out for a
reality tv show called american inventor
in between my first and second year at
business school i was at harvard
and we actually made it so this is
called american inventor is a precursor
to shark tank and uh long story short we
took this bicycle rack convention
licensed it to whirlpool we had a single
patent and they went and sold over a
million units through distribution
through low some people awesome um
so i decided not to go into finance
goldman made the right choice and not
extending me an offer they detected that
would have quit or been fired probably
fired day one uh
so then started a cloud a website backup
company i had a website crash
raised some money ian was an investor in
that 10 years ago we grew it to about
500 000 customers a million websites
backed up sold it for about 30 million i
don't know three years ago
around that time i've had my car broken
into the third time wow so just moved to
a different part of atlanta what i
thought was a really nice neighborhood
had been in two prior neighborhoods had
my car broken into and a neighbor's car
was stolen he left his key fob in the in
the middle of his his car and so i just
said i'm going to go on amazon and find
like ring for my car i'm going to go
find this thing
buy it and call today so i searched all
i could find were like the club old
school car alarms and uh
and like dash cams i forgot about the
club but like legit yeah that's what was
up yeah and then and then one of the top
recommendations i believe it was baby
cam so you take a baby cam because it's
close enough to your house you can put
it in the car and then see what's going
on
and so
i had an original idea did a
patentability search
and um it came back free and clear so
start working on the product while i was
uh i mean that must be
a holy grail scenario for someone with
your kind of skill set right like the
fact that like you're living like i
think scratching your own itch is always
the best start of a business
when you have when you're lucky enough
to be an engineer and you can actually
make it you know for me scratch my own
itch
in this scenario stops somewhere which
is i have no idea how to [ __ ] make
the thing for you that i mean that must
have been a really fun moment right
other parts of it i know how like
there's a microwave sensor inside of
this thing and the hardware where
there's a literally electrons bouncing
around inside of this that allows you to
detect someone outside of a car that is
like
way over my head so i've had to learn
painfully after a software company how
hard hardware is um
parvo is describing with the web group
code garbage partner with big hosting
providers co-skater and bluehost they'd
add us to the checkout list there's your
website back yep with that's how you got
your acquisition that's how we got it so
we grew i got it the claw we sold
through big box
so now you know i'm sitting through
these sessions and my mind is just blown
because the d2c and having an individual
conversation with a single customer
is uh it just feels very very
challenging yeah it's foreign to you
you've been you've been in the b2b
business very very foreign and so we've
raised four million dollars today we've
got 21 patents five of those issued we
launched a techcrunch disrupt
battlefield a month ago and right now
we're growing our wait list and trying
to potentially get some pre-orders and
we're thinking indiegogo or kickstarter
in the next month the next steps would
be a very wild idea for you but keep
going next what is the product oh so
this is a uh
it's hilarious so this is uh it goes in
your cup holder that's what i thought
and then you can still put a cup inside
of it
it will detect if there's any motion
outside your car and it will flash an
led ring and make a really loud chirping
noise and we call that deterrent mode of
course if they open the door these pir
sensors will detect them no false
positives it sounds 120 decibel blast
which is really really really loud
please
in your car it's an ambulance in your
car right so step one
if it gets too too close it's going to
show the person like you might want to
pick the next car
step two if the car is super fancy
ten percent of time people face people
breaking in so that that's big now dude
most people just walk around pull up on
door handles because
people are leaving their car door
unlocked or they've left their fob
inside of it so they walk around they
pull it in or actual theft you know
taking off with your car so
when we looked at this
most devices
got it so you're talking i'm sorry i
apologize on the first scenario you're
talking about people just taking [ __ ]
not taking the car taking the laptop out
of the bag you totally got it in the
door a billion dollars where the things
are taken from cars every year
where the car isn't even being taken
yeah and that's just being reported
which is being reported and there's so
much victim shaming of course because
someone's car gets broken into and
they're like did you did you leave it
unlocked yeah just some people like
honestly some people
are
in the place of like just realizing like
i'm not going to waste the time and
report this to police i'm going to go to
best buy and buy whatever the [ __ ] token
absolutely and if you report a police
and they say oh you know they don't have
anything they can recommend and so like
my neighbor's car was stolen the police
came around might have been rifled
through i had left it unlocked because i
really like her neighborhood i don't get
home and get paranoid about how bad the
neighborhood does get home and shoot
hoops with some of the kids in the
street
so one of the things is it anchors you
twist it'll anchor you install it
yourself
you connect it to power and then you
have a fob or use your phone so it'll
arm automatically and then it senses
your new walk up and disarms
automatically uh it'll record video if
someone does enter the car transmits it
to the cloud that's really cool uh you
can get the you can have professional
monitoring like simply safe they can
view it on your bed how much is the club
50 bucks ladies it's like 60 bucks yeah
60. how much will this be you're not
sure yet what do you think
50 bucks
there are two
there are two groups so we surveyed
customers and there's customers who view
like a 50 to 75 dollar price point and
there's
200 plus because they view it as alarm
system alarm system and then we have
safety capabilities so we can
i assume you get more excited when
people say 200
[Laughter]
is yeah i know when i bring out a
prototype they're pros and cons and i'm
not showing you the movie of course of
course
yeah to your point i can project
no no that's exactly right
by the way you're 100 right if you
showed me first at a production line and
you if you just do anything that
applifies it in the white box and shows
the app and the screen the justification
of a dollar up 199 versus 60 goes
through the roof
and by the way even the fact that i'm
sorry we were going to start at 299
that's understood
i understand and then we want to have a
lower end version down the road similar
to nest model where you start the
high-end tesla model start with a higher
end
there's you know what's so uniquely
fascinating about this from a consumer
lens and you'll probably want to spend a
little time on this is where does it
become price prohibitive
also matches the higher propensity for
theft and breakthrough so you're gonna
have to find that
mendoza line because
the people that don't have price
friction at 299 are also
less targeted less
feeling the pain and so finding that
right area is going to be that's in your
in this business hypothesis that's going
to be really fascinating yeah yeah i
think it's going to be really
interesting my street
i mean my my street in atlanta i think
some neighborhoods are targeted more
than others because on my street three
range rovers have been stolen one guy
was at the mall and so of course i mean
every city and state in the country has
though there's always
towns that begin to have a different
income level connected to the town that
does i mean it's just the most cliche
story of them all
so we think that price i did a survey i
ran google ads and found that they're
i interviewed 130 people
and
displayed it was really interesting can
i can i give you a much better way to do
that yes because i love the way you just
said that because it's very smart
before you do indiegogo or the thing i'm
about to throw at you
i would actually run
a website that looks like it's actually
functional
design the whole thing
a b c d test the pricing yeah when
they're done in the checkout
have a video of youtube saying thank you
for doing this
this is actually pre-launch
because we're trying to find the price
yeah because you completed the whole
order yeah you're gonna be one of our
first 500 people that's gonna get a free
one
from us
uh see you soon yeah okay because then
you'll get real clean data and i
actually do think
specifically for this product given that
it's hardware you got to produce it you
got to put it right it's different
than some of the stuff you've been
involved in i think it's worth going
through that process because then you'll
flat out see this will be not a survey
where humans
subconsciously know that you're
analyzing their data this will be i
actually think i'm buying this
i bought it for 149 i bought it for 299
i bought it for you'll get some very
clean data
something we're thinking about plus the
marketing of like the authenticity like
getting a video from you guys at the
checkout part when it's done like thanks
this is actually not ready yet this is
not even the real name of the product
yet this is not even the real price of
the product yet you though are gonna get
this because you just went all the way
through and bought it so we're thankful
you're the one of the first 500 people
to ever do that in the world and
if you do this now and in spring of 2022
we're gonna hand deliver you one to the
address you put in here as a thank you
for going all the way through there's a
lot that can happen there yes you'll get
the data you'll build a very small
community of very loyal people that feel
part of your community you might even
get like some marketing and
new coverage for your product because of
how unique that idea is yeah
where am i on timing okay so let me
sneak one quick thing on you and then
we'll get back to it if i can
i think the new indiegogo and gofundme
is nft projects
i wonder if you can get together with a
artist
and produce a thousand tokens 5 000
tokens
of really cool car art
where people buy it and that gives them
maybe even a piece of the business you
got to look at the sec and like where
all that is right now with the jobs act
and all that
but i'm completely convinced that the
future of fundraising is going to come
in nft form not in indiegogo and
gofundme because people have a double
asset play there
i actually think it's how every artist
is going to do album releases in the
future instead of going to a record
label they're going to have the fans be
a part of it
so something to put on your radar
awesome yeah because if you get an
artist
people have the collectible and some
sort of incentive and the nft represents
getting one of those so you buy that you
get that so you're you know now listen
you're selling the nft for 700 bucks
because it's a collectible and and it's
a cool piece of art car you're getting
the 300 item you're probably getting
more money that way and
and you can also then you also have them
part of your ecosystem so we can explain
that later i want to follow joe's lead
love your shirt by the way
thank you
so we talked a few months ago yes about
how to locate
cpas and financial planners to work with
me on my b2b mortgage yes and you talked
about setting up facebook facebook
groups
sacramento business alliance not yep
yeah and so i'm i'm still working on the
logistics there i've been super busy on
some other stuff no worries but please
do that so like
follow up with joe or whoever like it's
i'm really passionate about it and at
the time when we did that i
that bit was hot on my mind and i'm
starting to get the feedback loop from
people
that i set it to individually or i
mentioned a couple times publicly and
some podcasts it's really working for
people cool and just to get catch
everybody up the concept is if you're
trying to do local business
the facebook groups are doing so well
especially in that 40 to 75 year old
demo
that if you create something a little
more evergreen
literally back to your like back to the
prior one
the atlanta small business
facebook group it buckhead small
business group
or like you know like like
like denver
mom's club and if you're the host you're
the host and if you can build up that
group you can do localized marketing
inside of it
cool
um i also want to start looking at ways
to
probably run some targeted ads on
linkedin okay going after specific
companies that are the right size for
what i want yeah because what i really
need is i need a practice where it's one
guy in charge and he may have some
junior partners or maybe at the most
maybe three partners because when we get
much bigger than that
it's hard to get the buy-in from
everybody makes a ton of sense based on
what you're doing so
for me to do that do i actually target
the companies or do i go after just this
size of institutions if it depends on
what linkedin is gonna you know
sometimes when it's too small the
targeting capabilities are not there
okay so you have to pay a little more
for it to be a little more broad
but still get what you're looking for
okay do i run static ads or videos or
both okay the you know the number one
thing with social media ads that
everybody
misunderstands is it's the creative not
the media
okay
so try everything
because it's the only way you're gonna
get your math right okay the amount of
people that just decide that facebook
ads don't work because they ran three
ads
it's even back to the way we started
today
it's like
really squeezing the [ __ ] out of content
i mean we're living it right now for
wine techs quora
is a thing that's really working us
yeah i think i think all of you should
look at cora too answering questions and
running ads against the questions very
effective quora does extremely well with
google search it's not plain google
search there's sometimes price arbitrage
where a search term is like 19 bucks on
google ads but core is the first organic
answer and then you can buy the quora ad
for four bucks so you see where i'm
going with the arbs um
core could be really really good for a
lot of people here um
but uh where was it going now i remember
on the uh when i got off the plane today
i was talking to john morgenstern who
used to be ahead of all the vayner
media's planning of like what's the
right strategy
i've now brought him in to just work
with me directly my brand wine tax be
friends mainly because i think he'll be
even smarter working on this because the
clients don't let us do the best stuff
so he's almost working with me but it's
going to make the org much smarter
and it's already happened in a week
because he's the best of all time and
he's like me he loves to get his hands
dirty so like doing it again is fun for
him
we're crushing cora
but then there's fatigue like he hit me
up right now and he was like i need more
answers to different questions because
these three ads that are working are
fatigued
so it's always going to be more content
so in the linkedin example it's like
even when something's working you got to
do more and most people only run one or
two or three different variations of
creative and call it a day and decide if
a platform works when you're supposed to
do hundreds of variations
which is why i want everybody to do for
example i would love for you to start a
show to answer questions for those
brokers
so that you can then chop up the show
and run them as ads okay
so like it's even another move above
that which is like how are you gonna
keep creating so much ads
well what if you actually had a q a show
which is really in essence answering
that's the whole point of why q a works
askgaryvee was so brilliant because it's
no different than google ads google ads
work because it's intent based marketing
people are searching something they want
to answer
my q a show works because it's the
temperament tea with garyvee it works
because that's the current temperament
of what people want to know
one person usually represents 10 000
people's question
that's a good point so
what i'm thinking about that what i
think i'm going to do then is go to
the independent guys i'm already working
with who are doing the best at it and
interview them love that and then
that's it that that's a very fun job
that's a very good start but again if
you start if you start again the
sacramento you know real estate
brokerage like very long tail fake
groups you can extract new people
sacramento small business alliance that
goes very broad
sacramento brokerage you know mortgage
broker or real estate agents is more
narrow but will be very specific you
could oh by the way the world's about
and not or you can start both those
facebook groups
cool cool
appreciate it john morgenstern's pump
let's get over here
billy richardson um
my family has been in las vegas
since 1970 i love it
so i love it my family
my dad started out a small place grew it
so i've always been the hospital it's
always been a part of it i've always
watched him and how he grew sure
three blackjack tables to 12 slot
machines to growing it to where it was
so
um
so i got into the nightclub business
early in vegas there was only
three at the time and i was one of them
mine
54 to rio and watched all that and got
out of that one became
big money and yeah of course
of course
so i got into the restaurant business in
vegas
my thing is i grew up in vegas i'm very
local in vegas i believe in local
businesses in vegas and so
when i go and so i started with my first
restaurant at red rock it was a local
place i went in there i knew the guys
and i just pretended i knew how to make
hamburgers and do a hamburger restaurant
and
i did everything and hired guys and
we didn't even have a restaurant we got
our first one
i'm in the recession head in vegas and
so what year was that party what year
uh two thousand uh so when i get eight
nine i worked that win and left after
that lunacy but i learned a lot 2008
nine yeah yeah i sat in the restaurant
we were doing really well and watched
the spread screen of the
if they were gonna
pass the one um build that give him our
money and the stock market went through
the roof and they said no i just said
well
lehman brothers business and i watched
the whole casino empty out every day
but i got through it and then we grew
our business and we're a business
the thing i find hardest is
going and dealing with now with these
guys are for their wall street guys and
all they understand is guy fieri
thomas keller
shake shack
and i'm uh and i believe in las vegas i
love las vegas i grew up i have my kids
in las vegas
they're fourth generation third
but no one but these buildings don't
care about local guys anyway they don't
want local guys in there they want guys
that can pay big rent and stuff and and
i know it's i know it's super well yeah
i know it's super well and i sit there
and i go you know what i know i'm the
best in this business in vegas i know
the market better than anyone i get out
and i save but then i feel like well
then i'm being cocky or i'm doing this
and it's not that you're being cocky it
just doesn't mean anything to the people
that have the real estate locations that
you're referring to right and nothing
you say or do will change that right but
that's not a bad thing no that's only a
bad thing if that's the fixation of what
needs to happen
and i'm trying to learn about like
social media and stuff like that i i
i've hired pr firms i've done all that
and you know they tell me how great it
is you're not gonna have to do this and
this and this and i have one kid that
works for me
and i've been doing this for i have
if i have one hamburger pitcher i have
nine million
i've got one milkshake pitcher
from every season
halloween doesn't change christmas
doesn't change but i being here you know
i'm learning all this stuff now i have a
good tool of how to
use social media and i have two
people that live in my house a 15 year
old girl and a 10 year old girl and i
bounce stuff off them all the time and i
get this they're on their phones and i
go what brands do you guys like i don't
know dad
do you like holsteins that's my camera
yeah but shay check's better dad okay
yeah listen i get i get it too i get it
too what i try to learn is that someone
taught me that if i have a 15 or 15 year
olds now in five years or six years
they're going to be 21 they're gonna be
coming to vegas
how do i get them to become my customer
what what is your business so you have
did you say you had four locations or
locations so one one is um i do
hamburgers and milkshakes primarily and
then one is all pizzas
and and then all hot dogs we do lobster
rolls and hamburgers okay so i
specialize in i see it yeah and where
what uh
where are you
i'm in the resort world i'm in the lane
so you're in the places oh yeah i'm in
giant traffic areas like holsteins
that's massive yes
i'm trying to get locals to come down
because vegas has done these guys have
done a really good job saying we don't
want locals to come down we're gonna
charge parking
paper parking yeah i mean as some you
know
i i have a real sense of this market i
almost bought
the
uh minor league baseball team
uh with tony shea who unfortunately
passed i was very involved in downtown
in the early days i was really friendly
with tony at the time and spent a lot of
time analyzing the market because i was
going to bet the farm and buying a minor
league baseball team
um
here are my here are my kind of couple
concerns or thoughts one
i hate
friction
uh like fighting reality is always a
losing formula in business
you know this way better than i do back
to generation three i learned this after
four months of very good homework
getting locals to come to your place is
not mathematically right for them
the [ __ ] are they gonna do that for
one strategy you could have is actually
opening a fifth location in a local
place
building equity that way and then when
they do happen to go
to the places there's that residual
brand affinity
that is like a macro strategy to think
about
the other the other thing to think about
is
how do you
create differentiation
inside those places
forget about the famous chefs and things
of that nature the reality is is that
very concise marketing within the
feeds of social can always work no
matter what the circumstances are so
running very aggressive ads
to
the vegas you know
area code over and over and over is
going to have residual
effects it's going to come down to the
creative
um
but
but i think
let's break these down because i assume
the four locations you have and i've got
a sense of what you've got going on
that game is very real estate driven
like whatever location you have you have
those patterns in those casinos are
consistent
and you've got a pretty good sense of
what that is
rightfully so as an entrepreneur you're
like okay so this is what it is
and my growth can come if i can get
locals to come down
or just more people are even just
generating more in the united states and
worldwide because of the people that are
coming yeah but it's not going to work
that way i don't think unless you do
ridiculous [ __ ]
right like the virality and consistency
that you'll need for like me to see it
on my tic toc and then remember in nine
months like there's so much branding
that has to go into that
to me this starts so i would tell you
what i would do i think that if i'm your
partner i would say
uh
we need to start at the product level
so let me give you an example something
i've always loved about this kind of
food
i think you should create a 200 hot dog
well i have i have a billionaire burger
it's a billion dollars
uh no okay what is it
it's a hundred
and i have other people and then they
tell me well no one's going to do it and
i i have thought of saying well this
burger's a billion dollars and someone
will buy it yeah i see like when the the
million dollar
i think what you need to do is create
multiple food items per place that are
so outlandish and are content driven so
here's what you could here's what i
would do
i would create a 99
slice of pizza for the pizza place i
would think about what the [ __ ] that
means is that caviar is that some sort
of like weird ostrich egg or am i
pouring in am i cook am i pouring dom p
over it after it comes out of the oven i
don't know what it does but you have
gotta it can't just be 99 bucks you
actually kind of have to try to get it
there that's number one number two
i would have somebody full-time hired
for your four locations in the in the
main casinos
that goes into tick-tock and instagram
uses the hashtag las vegas
search sorts it by recent
sees who's just posted because it's
proving that they're in vegas and dming
them to come to the place to get a free
piece of the outlandish product
if you if you create the bait and then
bring them in and you're giving me and
if you hit up drock because he somehow
has a lot of followers
um
and we're in vegas a lot for a speech
and you dm him and say
hey drock we love your work we'd love
you to come in and get a free 100 slice
of pizza there's two things that happen
there one he'll probably do it because i
know him two
the hundred dollars will catch him off
guard even if he wasn't gonna do it
that might make him do it like you're
like what is what is that even i do
believe that would work i really do
i think you you you know and i'm just
i'm trying to let me break it down one
more time because i really want to make
sure you get it because i'm going to
move on
one to two ridiculous items you're
already in aligned with me because you
have 100 burger so you're already there
one to two items that are really
outlandish rethink them because the 100
burger potentially should be refurbished
because you thought about it maybe with
a different context point
you need to make it so visually
interesting that when the influencer
comes for the free thing they're going
to want to make you're not going to ask
that the second you say drock comment if
you post on your instagram we'll give
you 100
burger you're already dead
if you just say hey we see that you're
here we love your stuff come in ask for
carl the manager and we'll give you the
100 milkshake when that person gets 100
milkshake you know you you clearly want
them to do the thing we want them to do
you have to make it so visually
ridiculous that they themselves want to
do it because it's good content
you need to hire a full-time person to
constantly stay on tick-tock and
instagram to see who's hashtagged vegas
and dming them you need a full-time
person right got it yes awesome thank
you i appreciate it yeah thanks
to monique
oh that's interesting
so one of my biggest uh
challenges right now is
we had a uh you know
in the sports and athletic
space where you have athletes who have
gone to shows and they they travel and
drink pandemic that was all shut down
and they said you know we can really
have our price point a lot higher for
direct to consumer yeah but we're
competing against the fanatics against
yes we talked about that right so what
what is your uh thought in terms of the
feasibility of something like that uh
for us to create our own like legend
circle agency for direct-to-consumer
merchandise for other for other people
besides jim uh-huh
i think it's real yeah you know i think
there's a lot of fragmentation available
in talent
that's why you know that's why there's
so many managers it's why there's so
many agencies
um i think the feasibility is very real
i think the question you have to ask and
we obviously have a little bit of a
preview of this because you and i spoke
recently about this
it's going to come down to how good you
are at it the problem with like you know
do i think that jim
and you and and somebody you hire or
somebody on the team reaches out to 12
hall of famers and say are you really
happy with the way you have it we're
starting this thing would you come you
know you know this better than i do i'm
just around it a lot
legends trust other legends more than
they trust somebody else trying to get
in their pocket so do i think you can
get six people roger starbuck this or
all cable of course i do i think you can
the problem is that you also know this
part a year later if they're selling
less helmets with you
even if they're you know if the money's
not the same or better then they're
gonna start saying wait maybe i should
go back to upper deck maybe i should go
to so i think the question there the
feasibility is incredibly real
very real and forever real
the question is how much belief do you
have that you can build the organization
that can create that demand i'm not
scared you know about you know as much
as i love michael rubin fanatics and i
do they're real homies
do i think there's fragmentation of
course i do because it's happening it's
there's a lot of fragmentation i think
the question becomes can you create the
demand creation outside of you know john
elway putting a link in his instagram
saying this is where my memorabilia is
you're gonna need you're gonna need more
than that much more than that so are you
an organization you become a retailer
right how good of a retailer are you
and that's right i think the ideology
always gets people going right they're
like yeah we're gonna get 50 of the
action instead of 20 but 50 of 17 signed
balls is a lot less money than 20 of 20
000 balls and i think i think that's the
thing you're gonna have to figure out
that's right and that's really where we
are in terms of the feasibility of it
i mean the other thing is look for you
specifically your guys situation you're
at such the tippy top of it that you
could leave for a year and if you
decided oops we need to go back every
major player is going to be very
thrilled to have that convo with you so
you got to keep that in mind too yeah
yeah we wouldn't do it ourselves yeah we
definitely have a team we build the team
around it
to
that that's the decision you're making
do you believe that this team with
better economics can close the gap on a
team that's out there that's been doing
it at the scale that whoever you're with
i don't have that fully figured that's
missing like what is it that they're not
doing correct
that's right and what can you add to it
access virtual access content all that
stuff
but but let me say this when you because
i've seen a lot
don't get over romanced with the better
percentages right a lot of people lose
on that game
because in your specific thing unlike
other you know there's it's one thing
when you're
i'll tell you my story as a public
speaker when i looked at the
data after two years with caa yeah and
at first it was great because i
god rest his soul when tony shea would
say no and i was at caa they'd be like
how about this guy gary vaynerchuk he
talks about similar stuff so that was
great for me but as my brand got to a
different place the last two years i was
caa 85
of my speaking engagements came through
my website
then you're like well i'm creating the
demand
um
so i think the demand creation is always
going to have the leverage
yeah that's right not how good is the
deal that's right got it that's the key
absolutely and it's hard to compete for
traffic
it's almost like we have to
cross-promote amongst like the various
projects that we have
but the scale yeah but the scale in
which and and what are we talking
exclusive and then you think about
friction for the consumer right you know
like if i'm looking for you know i'm
gonna go to google or i'm gonna go
directly to fanatics maybe upper deck
and type in his name ebay right that'd
be the other place i'd go
you got to think those things through
yeah i definitely can begin to feel that
obviously fanatics has a footprint
that's way larger in this space but
there's so many other areas that they're
not as big in i agree you know certain
types of apparel or even lacrosse as a
growing sport so kind of and jim's i
mean you know what i feel about his
opportunity with lacrosse and telling
that story yeah
okay you might be able to carve some
stuff out too exactly he's so like
revered absolutely that i could see i
think some i think some companies might
even be willing to compromise and say if
you said hey we want to do all our own
lacrosse stuff can we have that
exclusively i think you might find some
yeses because they might think it's too
small and they have too much respect for
him and then you can test
maybe you start there i mean he is the
greatest lacrosse player of all time
thank you
awesome yeah gary yeah
so i am
working on my next startup and uh
i am thinking about kind of how do i
help the masses right i've always built
niche sites and investing you know
dividends mutual funds
so
just talking to my daughter one day
she's 25 she's like hey you know that if
it wasn't for you
me and my friends would never invest
like you know you keep me up to date and
whatnot so i'm like wow that's like a
big audience mid-20s not investing i
mean i mean and now
right the whole robin hood phenomenon i
mean you have more 20 year olds it's now
it's like cool culture to be a traitor
yeah yeah
and i think that's the thing you know
everyone's into that but the problem
then is
people get intimidated right so like my
daughters aren't thinking about like oh
you don't want to trade crypto i'm going
to trade this right so
my thing is i came up with this idea the
investing superstore so you think about
a superstore you think about walmart
target yeah everything superstore
superstore sorry i heard superstars the
investment's super slow keep going so
the idea is to have
any asset that you can buy
in one location okay
so partnering up with a different sort
of platform so if you want to buy
fractional shares of a rookie card you
want to buy stocks you want to buy
crypto
whatever the asset is partner work with
these companies and everything is done
in one place
so the idea is
are you gonna do that are you gonna are
you gonna do that through apis are you
gonna be able to so be built like the
amazon
interesting you know so like a discovery
engine so people that bought this asset
also bought these assets yep so the idea
is to build the anti robin hood right
because rob manhattan is very gamified
it's trading i want to build something
that's more zen right i guess i've been
in san diego five years
yeah so i'm in this very like zen no
noise i don't want any alerts from wall
street no upgrades downgrades earnings
reports
i just want people to buy assets
well
won't that only work for people who are
further along in their knowledge base if
you're if you make a very zen place
where i'm just transacting and nobody's
bothering me i love that comma
won't i have to be pretty damn
knowing what the [ __ ] i want to buy when
i go in there yeah well there'll be an
education part right okay there's
you know the education basics
my hot take
and we've got more to go through but my
hot take is
i've always historically struggled when
somebody wants to be a consolidator of
information coming from other sources
because it's a dangerous business let me
explain
it's very hard to win that game
because once
first of all it's hard to get people to
come to a new place
and that takes a lot of money
it's a theme
two
if you're even able to succeed in that
which is a monumental win
when you're relying on apis or other
data sets
if you become too big they shut it off
right because they don't want you they
don't want to pay you the vig
so so that's one thing to think through
yeah well like this you know the way i
thought about it was like lead
generation right so we're selling them
and i have a good enough sense of like
how you came up so it makes sense to me
so it's you know so it's lead generation
the flip side you know the other aspect
that we thought originally was this
chrome extension
metamask
yeah or even like you know join honey
yep
so even to create something where we can
see what's in your car and say hey
there's
five of the 12 things are investable i
think the question becomes the following
so the hypothesis of everybody being an
investor in their 20s is very real
that let's start there the macro
hypothesis that is super real
the
amount of content on tick tock right now
like of like actual investing advice
that 16 and 17 year olds are taking very
seriously between sneakers and sports
cards and definitely nfts and crypto and
stock and robin hood life and the whole
gamestop stuff it is
enough has happened that i would bet the
farm on
what's going to happen with 20 year old
behavior on investing so that's great
the
the thing that you're thinking about my
first reaction on the next part is
you're taking a very web 1.0 approach to
it consolidation fragmentation arbitrage
i do like the extension a little bit
more
i i think
i think
all of them are going to do it
coinbase robin hood and these these
platforms have tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of users already
and they're going to continue to
verticalize and horizontalize offerings
so the superstore thing doesn't fire me
up because i think that's the road map
of all the people you're competing with
that have 100 million user head start
and billions in fundraising head start
so that's one thing to just be open-eyed
to yeah yeah i don't think that's enough
of a moat
yeah well the most part that i was going
to add in was the community part right
so that now that we by the way always
yeah so like we don't like the same
asset
if we can create the communities but
that's a chicken and egg thing right
like what size of scale does a community
need to be to be a
it needs to be pretty large and like how
do you get them there and why
it's why i'm so in love with content i
always think the content
at the end of the day always is the
lowest friction point to creating
community
um yeah i mean i think the superstore
thing is concerning just because i have
a good enough read on what robin hood
and coinbase and others even the like
everyone's battling for the same thing
now
right the macro superstore thing scares
me the super macro hypothesis i'm in
love with
like the whole like that the way this
started like hey dad me and my friends
are being like that's huge because it's
real yeah i just
wonder where you should put that energy
yeah yeah the investor rest was like the
brand that we had for the chrome
extension idea right which is like now
you're in your car it's like hey look do
do i think that that can work as a
chrome extension i really do
yeah is that the best is that the best
use of a four year period
to like build that up and the amount of
dollars to like customer acquire is what
i'm really thinking through because i
love that you're on the macro macro
and sometimes
i've done this a lot i've been so right
about the macro macro but where i put my
energy was getting nickels instead of
dollars against a very proper macro
macro hypothesis yeah
like if i was smart enough that would be
the word i would use to realize what i
was doing in 1996 with open cart
optimization because i knew i had a
website and i knew that people were
stuck and didn't check out mainly
because i used to be petrified of the
tech because i just always thought our
site didn't work because it was so early
and it was [ __ ] very hard and i
wasn't an engineer and even though i
hired and like it was just like an
everyday thing for me is our site broken
like what's like it was just so that's
why web 3 comes so natural to me
everyone's all scared about nfts i'm
like this is 1996.
like nobody knows what the [ __ ] in a you
know a custodial wallet is of course
people are getting like it's it's a
different shift um
i
if i instead of thinking about selling
pinot noir for my dad
commercialized and productized open card
optimization i'd have i would have owned
the jets in 2002.
that's kind of like a sense i'm getting
here which is like
i'm not scared of anything you said
i just love your macro macro thesis so
much that i want to make sure you
pressure test yourself on where you're
going to deploy your attack on it yeah
you see where i'm going yeah i think
that's kind of where i'm at i i get that
i respect that i can tell you one thing
and this is for all of you
content while you're debating is a good
idea yeah you starting a tick tock and
being aggressive about it on
investing 101 advice from your
perspective is a really good idea yeah
yeah it's funny i like the part you said
about sassing right
because like i'm sort of like i'm not a
big fan of uh the things that happened
like you know on cnbc you know and i
don't know if you know do you have
tick-tock
i don't i don't good let me tell you a
theme in tik-tok
a thing that's done in tic-tac-toe crush
for you you can green screen it's a very
common meme in tick tock where
something's playing in the background
and you're social commentating your
ability to like
if you're not pumped with cnbc film
stuff
then talk over it while it's playing
will work real well with the kids
because cnbc is their dad's channel
right so you'll win them over real fast
with that that's interesting yeah
because i'm thinking about sort of the
content and by the way social
commentating on top of a piece of
content is the easiest way to create
content
it's your hot take on what you say yes
sir one last question yes of course
yeah i know he's good like that
so you uh
you get the device yes it's gonna be
ready may june of next year
uh we we have raised funds we have money
to spend on marketing yes if you're in
our position where you've got a
prototype device that's what we have we
don't have
we don't have a bunch of production
devices to ship to influencers yes
when will you
um
could could be in the next three months
maybe within the next three months so
yeah
our challenge right now is if we can
launch in there if you were fewer us and
we're launching in may
how would you drum up as much attention
as you could now with you know we do
have a considerable marketing budget let
me i'll give you a bunch of things i
think i got a lot for you so
one i think you should really debate
doing an nft project i really do i think
you should find an artist in atlanta
maybe two there's tons of good artists
out there that's not the issue and
literally design an nft project and
everybody who buys an mt gets the piece
when it comes out you're gonna have to
decide what the price is so you can
communicate so that's over here that's
one thing really to be i know that's
very progressive and early and i could
kill that because it's so new
number two speaking to nfts
i
i don't know if you know what discord is
but discord and
facebook groups i think a facebook group
around literally the group's called
tired of getting your car [ __ ] with
group
you know it's funny there's one in
kansas city it's like 300 000 members in
it
it's just real
i love that
i think you should own the party instead
of watching the party so i think you
should start your own facebook groups
because that's gonna be your customers
eventually that's another thing
i think that you should make an
animation
kind of
uh cartoon or stick figure i think you
should try to get the lowest cost three
videos of re-enacting how the product
works
for content now
right so
think about how fun you can make some of
that if it's cartoon if it's a pretty
cool cartoon explainer video right now
that's actually
good send that over to me on email it's
gary vaynermedia i want to see it i want
you to make it not for the website to
explain i want you to make it for social
media content demand creation and i'm
sure you can tell how that would be
different one yours is probably very
literal
i want these to be a little more fun and
just like cause virality um i would hire
i would definitely when we get closer
um do some hardcore influencer tiktok
work the skits
on tick tock with your product that can
go crazy viral is pretty extreme
i mean it's just
made for comedy and made for tick tock
and i think you're one
three thousand dollar
influencer campaign away from having
outrageous levels of awareness would you
start with a hundred small influencers
would you go after two or three big ones
i mean the answer is both can work i
think what i'd probably do right away is
make sure both of you actually get
serious about downloading tick tock and
just like spending 15 minutes a day
like
using it so that you are a better judge
and jury of who you do something with
the biggest issue for everybody
yeah
how would i best do research
so
yeah
you'll love this not your category i
just want you to have the the tone and
temperament of tick tock there's
probably not a whole lot of carl alarm
car stealing content what i want you to
do back to where your your partner in
crime here he referenced basketball and
has a basketball shirt on good let him
[ __ ] like
have his stream filled with that
basketball content i just want both of
you to have a taste of the temperament
you're not gonna find content around you
what you're gonna find probably along
the way
it what i hope my my dream is on march
9th you're just doing you're staying the
course 10 minutes a day you're just
going through and you're like enjoying
it as a human you find something that
really makes you laugh you click on the
person they've got 87 000 followers you
look at their other six videos you're
like this person's [ __ ] good
this is me dreaming oh [ __ ] this person
lives in you know in alabama not too too
far you message the person go i love
your stuff would you consider doing
something for a brand
you see where i'm going
that's like my dream state it doesn't
have to be that lucky it could be it's
something else but be at some point in
based on your timing in april or may i'm
gonna want you to spend ten thousand
bucks on two or three or four or five
influencer campaigns and i want you to
be dramatically
back to pr back to lovely gentlemen to
the left
people waste money
when they don't know how to judge it
the amount of people that have wasted a
fortune on
almost everybody who tells me that
social media doesn't work i already know
exactly what happened
they
they wanted to try it out because they
were scared to waste money
they went with someone that's [ __ ]
either completely full of [ __ ] or just
is [ __ ] and they don't even realize it
because it's small
they do their thing it doesn't work and
they decide after three months of
[ __ ] putting two thousand bucks a
month into some horse [ __ ] that that
doesn't work that's like me going
outside right now and dribbling a
basketball not being good at it and
saying that basketball isn't a viable
option you have to be good at it yeah so
you need to know
you understand why i brought up tick
tock so much
from 2011 to 2013 if you were the best
in the world at running facebook ads you
built a huge company
in 2015 to 2017 if you were the best at
the world being an influencer on
instagram you really built something big
we are in it right now and we've
probably got another 12 to 24 months
where you're just getting better deals
from tick tock than tick tock is getting
from you and then they tip
right now everyone on instagram that's
one dimensional instagram's crying their
organic reaches down it's harder they're
not growing as fast they're not making
as much money well you know they love
they're mad at the algorithm [ __ ]
instagram meanwhile they don't instagram
doesn't charge you anything and you
built your whole career on it you just
had good timing and you got it when it
was good tick tock's got that right now
and i just need everybody to go hard at
it because it will go away
just like instagram went away just like
twitter went away just like facebook
went away it's the same game every time
it's the real estate version of
attention
you either buy beachfront property first
or you don't
and it gets progressively worse deal
tick-tock is where all the cranes is
that's what you're saying that's exactly
right
it's just where the attention is and
it's not 15 year olds anymore it's 30
40. like it's it's this is a rodeo i've
seen before
you know so i think i think and i what i
love about your product for tick tock
unlike instagram perfect marketing four
years ago where it was just a nice image
of your product with a little click here
and you go to your website and you
convert and you cookie them and you
retarget them now with ios 14 update you
can't retarget the same way but on tick
tock for your product one aspiring
comedian does the right hilarious video
of somebody's scared [ __ ] list of trying
to steal the car and it gets 14 million
organic views
you're off to the races
that's all we got for you man thank you
so much such a pleasure
good to see you again
thanks for being here yeah it really is
good to be back in person like really
good the zoom version of this is just
not as fun
i love it it's efficient
awesome thank you thanks gang continued
success yeah
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment and
exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you